If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the rest is history.com and click Gifts. At Desjardin Insurance, we put the care in taking care of business. Your business, to be exact. Our agents take the time to understand your company, so you get the right coverage at the right price. Whether you rent out your building, represent a condo corporation, or own a cleaning company, We make insurance easy to understand
如果你想了解本节目的更多内容，请加入“一切皆历史”俱乐部。随着圣诞节的临近，你还可以为身边的历史爱好者送上一整年的会员权限。只需访问 the rest is history.com 并点击“礼物”。在道尔顿保险，我们全心全意为您排忧解难，确切地说，是为您的生意保驾护航。我们的保险经纪会花时间了解您的公司，确保您以合适的的价格获得合适的保障。无论您是出租楼宇、代表公寓公司，还是拥有清洁公司，我们都让保险通俗易懂，
so you can focus on the big stuff, like your small business. Get insurance that's really big on care. Find an agent today at Dejardin.com slash business coverage. At Capital One, we're more than just a credit card company. We're people just like you who believe in the power of yes.
这样您就能专注于大事，比如您的小型企业。获得真正注重关怀的保险。今天就访问 Dejardin.com slash business coverage 寻找保险经纪。在第一资本，我们不仅仅是一家信用卡公司。我们和您一样，坚信“说行”的力量。
Yes to new opportunities. Yes to second chances. Yes to a fresh start. That's why we've helped over four million Canadians get access to a credit card because at Capital One, we say yes, so you don't have to hear another no. What will you do with your yes?
对新机遇说行。对第二次机会说行. 对崭新的开始说行。这就是为什么我们已经帮助超过四百万加拿大人成功申请到信用卡，因为在第一资本，我们总是说“行”，这样你就不用再听到“不”字。你会用你的“行”来做些什么？
Get the yes you've been waiting for at Capital One.ca slash yes. Terms and conditions apply. This Giving Tuesday, Cam H is counting on your support. Together, we can forge a better path for mental health by creating a future where Canadians can get the health they need when they need it, no matter who or where they are. From November 25th to December 2nd,
快来 Capital One.ca slash yes 获取你一直在等待的“行”吧。需遵守相关条款和条件。在这个“乐施星期二”，加拿大心理健康协会（CAMH）正指望您的支持。通过创造一个让加拿大人在需要时能够获得所需健康的未来，无论他们是谁，身在何处，我们就能共同为心理健康开辟一条更好的道路。从 11 月 25 日到 12 月 2 日，
your donation will be doubled. That means every dollar goes twice as far to help build a future where no one's seeking help is left behind. Donate today at camh.ca.ca slash giving Tuesday. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionized the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke,
您的捐款将翻倍。这意味着每一美元都会发挥双倍的作用，帮助构建一个不让任何寻求帮助的人掉队的未来。今天就前往 camh.ca slash giving Tuesday 捐款。本集由 Hive 赞助。英国曾凭藉工业力量的威力彻底变革了未来。但现在，您可以利用 Hive 的力量，自己重塑能源未来并掌控主动。Hive 充分利用太阳能，太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并让您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。Hive 的恒温器让您无需动手，只需动动大拇指和带着赞许的目光，就能为房屋供暖。它们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其精确保持在您想要的位置。没有烟雾，
no waste. Hive's EV charger lets your car charge quietly overnight, recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together, heating, charging and solar, managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more, subject to survey and suitability.
没有浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让您的汽车在夜间静音充电，在您休息的同时补充电量。Hive 将供暖、充电和太阳能集于一体，通过一个简单的应用程序进行管理，这是一场静悄悄的革命。在漫长的电力历史中，Hive 助您最终了解属于您的力量。前往 hivehome.com 了解更多信息，需经实地勘测和评估。
Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for a surplus requires SEG tariff. Hello everyone and welcome to Abbey Road Studios for a Rest is History Beatles special. Now I am afraid that Dominic isn't here because as regular listeners will know, he disgraces himself by not liking John Lennon and also being fed up with talking about the Beatles and we were recently the pair of us on Conan O'Brien's podcast and Conan asked us were we Beatles or Stones I of course said Beatles Dominic said stones and then said I am never going to talk about the Beatles again so when I got the opportunity to do a Beatles podcast
Hive 应用程序兼容指定技术。获得盈余补贴需要 SEG 资费。大家好，欢迎来到阿比路录音室，收听“一切皆历史”披头士乐队特辑。恐怕多米尼克今天没来，因为经常收听的听客都知道，他居然不喜欢约翰·列侬，而且也厌倦了谈论披头士，这实在是有失身份。我们俩最近上了柯南·奥布莱恩的播客，柯南问我们是更喜欢披头士还是滚石乐队。我当然选了披头士，多米尼克选了滚石，然后说：“我再也不想谈论披头士了。”所以当我得到这个机会来录制披头士播客时，
here in Abbey Road I thought well who can I get to replace Dominic, who can be Denny Lane to my Paul McCartney. And so I thought, well, Conan O'Brien and Conan, here you are, Ian Abbey Road. I just flew 35,000 miles to be called Denny Lane to your Paul McCartney. And I accept it. It's a high honor. Thank you so much for joining us. Because when we met in L.A., you were talking about how you two are a massive Beatles fan.
在阿比路录音室里，我想，谁能来代替多米尼克呢？谁能成为我保罗·麦卡特尼的丹尼·莱恩？于是我想，好吧，柯南·奥布莱恩，柯南，你来了，在阿比路。我刚飞了三万五千英里，就是为了当你的保罗·麦卡特尼的丹尼·莱恩。我接受了。这是极大的荣幸。非常感谢你能加入我们。因为我们在洛杉矶见面时，你提到你们两个都是披头士的超级粉丝。
But more than that, you talked about how you've actually met. George and Paul and Ringo. Yeah, yeah, I was lucky enough to meet three of the four Beatles. John died when I was in high school, but I was a Beatles fan in the 70s to the exclusion of music that was coming out at the time. I was stubbornly just listening to Beatles records throughout the 70s. But later on, once I had a TV show and became known, I was lucky to meet three of them, which was really special.
但更重要的是，你谈到你其实见过乔治、保罗和林戈。是的，是的，我很幸运见到了四位披头士中的三位。约翰在我上高中时就去世了，但我在 70 年代就是披头士的歌迷，甚至到了排斥当时其他流行音乐的地步。在整个 70 年代，我都极其顽固地只听披头士的唱片。但后来，自我有了电视节目并崭露头角后，我有幸见到了他们中的三位，这真的非常特别。
I met George when I was a writer at Saturday Night Live, and he was meeting with Lorne Michaels, who's a producer. They had gone out for drinks. And then there's a writer's room at Saturday Night Live, and George came in. I'll never forget. He apologized initially because he had been drinking some quantity of liquor. So he said, I'm sorry, I'm pissed as a newt. And he was kind of bobbing from shoe to shoe.
我第一次见乔治是在《周六夜现场》担任编剧的时候，他当时正在和制片人洛恩·迈克尔斯会面。他们出去喝了酒。然后《周六夜现场》的编剧室里来了乔治。我永远不会忘记。他一开始就先道了歉，因为他之前喝了不少酒。所以他说：“对不起，我烂醉如泥。”他一边说着，一边双脚摇晃着。
asked why we were all staring at him, me being a Beatles geek, I had in my office the same make model year country gentleman that George played in the 64 tour. And I thought about going and getting it and showing it to him, but I thought, no, he's not in a condition to appreciate that. He'll probably hit me with it. And then George sat down at a piano and started to play, which was lovely. And what was he playing? He was just playing around chords. He was wasn't playing a song. Yeah, so not My Guitar Gently Weeps. No, it wasn't what you think.
问我们为什么都盯着他看，作为一个披头士迷，我办公室里摆着一把和乔治在 64 年巡演中弹奏的一模一样、同年份的乡村绅士吉他。我曾想过去把它拿来展示给他看，但我想，不，他现在的状态可欣赏不了这个。他可能会用它砸我。然后乔治坐到钢琴前开始弹奏，这太美妙了。他弹的是什么？他只是在随意弹奏和弦。他没有在弹具体的歌。对，所以不是《我的吉他轻轻哭泣》。不，不是你想的那样。
Hollywood would make it a full rendition of While My Guitar Gently Weeps. It was not. So you were listening to a Beatle play the piano. I was listening to a Beatle play the piano. And I've also been lucky enough to be in a room where Paul was playing guitar. And it was just a guitar that was in the room. So he's left-handed. He was just playing it upside down.
好莱坞会把它拍成《我的吉他轻轻哭泣》的完整演奏版。其实并不是。所以你在听一个披头士成员弹钢琴。我是在听一个披头士成员弹钢琴。而且我也很幸运，曾身处保罗弹吉他的房间里。那只是房间里随手拿的一把吉他。所以他是左撇子。他只是把吉他上下倒过来，
and backwards and I said how do you do that what did you learn to do that and he said to me back in the day when we were starting out I had to because the only other way to play it would be to retune John's guitar and he would have crippled me I can't believe that you've you've you've had these experiences because the closest that I have come to meeting Beatles was via my wife Sadie when she was three was in a queue with her parents for a visa to America. And Paul was standing behind her and picked her up. I was in that queue as well.
反着弹。我说：“你怎么做到的？你是怎么学会这样弹的？”他告诉我：“当年我们刚出道时，我不得不这么做，因为唯一的其他弹法就是给约翰的吉他重新调音，那样他会把我弄残的。”我真不敢相信你竟然有过这些经历，因为我离见到披头士最近的一次经历，是通过我妻子萨蒂，她三岁时曾和父母在去美国的签证排队队伍中。
So I've got you beat at every turn. Oh, God. So you're a huge Beatles fan. Yeah. As am I. But there are, of course, skeptics out there. Dominic being one of them. Yes.
保罗就站在她身后，把她抱了起来。我也在那个队伍里。那我可真是处处都比你抢先一步啊。天哪。所以你是披头士的超级大粉丝。是的。我也是。但当然，世上总有怀疑论者。多米尼克就是其中之一。是的。
So I guess the question, we're a history podcast rather than a music podcast. So we need to make the case that the Beatles are historically significant. Yes. Is that a case you think that can be made? Easily. the Beatles are a complete break with what happened before they are singer-songwriters they wrote their own music there are so many ways that they depart so many groups at the time you know there's the lead and then there's the rest of the group it's you know dion and the belmont's there was a lot of pressure for them to have a leader i think briefly they were johnny and the moon dogs very briefly but they always knew no it's It's, we're a group. So it's kind of synergy of it.
我想问题在于，我们是一个历史播客，而不是音乐播客。所以我们需要证明披头士乐队具有历史意义。是的。你认为这个观点能够成立吗？轻而易举。披头士乐队与他们之前出现的事物有着彻底的决裂。他们是唱作人，自己创作音乐。他们与当时许多乐队决裂的方式有太多种了。你知道的，当时通常是一个主唱加上乐队的其他成员，比如迪恩和贝尔蒙特乐队。当时他们承受着很大压力，必须要有一个主唱，我想他们短暂地叫过“约翰尼和月亮狗乐队”，非常短暂。但他们一直很清楚，不，我们是一个团队。所以这是一种协同效应。
Yeah. And that was unusual at the time. So they're a break with pretty much everything that comes before them. And they're as relevant today as they were in 1964. Because obviously there have been acts that have been massive in their own time and then slightly have started to fade. But I guess you could say that the Beatles have endured long enough and remain massive enough. Yeah.
是的。这在当时很不寻常。因此，他们与几乎在此之前的一切事物都划清了界限。而且他们在今天依然像 1964 年时那样具有时代 relevance（现实意义）。因为显然有些乐队在他们那个时代红极一时，随后便开始逐渐黯淡。但我想你可以说，披头士乐队历经足够长的时间，至今依然影响力巨大。是的。
That you can say that people will probably be listening to them in decades times, maybe in centuries time. Yeah. There's a great clip. I think it's in the anthology where they're talking to a young guy, basically a teenager, a kid at Shea Stadium. And the interviewer's trying to run them down a little bit. And this kid says, I love them. Yeah. And he just says they're incredible musicians.
你可以断言，几十年后，甚至几个世纪后，人们可能依然会听他们的歌。是的。有一个很棒的片段。我想是在纪录片《精选集》里，他们在采访一个年轻人，基本上是个十几岁的孩子，在谢伊体育场的孩子。采访者试图稍微贬低他们一下，而这个孩子却说：“我爱他们。”是的。他直接说他们是不可思议的音乐家。
And he more or less makes the kids. case there in 1965 or six that we're going to be listening to their music forever. They are, I think, the best-selling musical act of all time. Every statistic that they generate is off the scale. I guess the case I would make and why I think they're historically significant is because in a way, they are lightning rods for so much that makes the 60s a revolutionary decade. And I think that in all kinds of ways in the time. 21st century, we're living in the aftermath of what happened in the 60s, rather like people
他在 1965 年或 1966 年就差不多证明了：人们将永远听他们的音乐。我认为他们是有史以来最畅销的音乐艺人。他们产生的每一项统计数据都突破天际。我想我给出的理由以及我认为他们具有历史意义的原因是，在某种程度上，他们就像避雷针一样，吸引了那么多让 20 世纪 60 年代成为一个革命性十年的元素。我认为在当今的方方面面，
in the 16th century were living in the aftermath of what had happened in the 1520s. I think the transformation, the cultural, the ethical transformation is on that scale. And the Beatles are both kind of symbols of it, but they're also vectors of it. Yeah. I mean, the Beatles themselves knew that they weren't creating all this change. Sometimes they were just the avatar. They could represent the change. And I think they were pretty sane. I mean, another group with that kind of fame would have said, we did all this.
我们都生活在 60 年代所发生事件的余波之中，就像 16 世纪的人们生活在 1520 年代所发生事件的余波中一样。我认为这种变革，即文化和道德上的变革，就是这种规模的。而披头士既是这种变革的象征，也是它的载体。是的。我的意思是，披头士自己也知道并非他们在创造所有这些变化。有时他们只是化身。他们能够代表这种变化。而且我认为他们相当清醒。我的意思是，换作其他享有那种名气的乐队，早就会说：“这一切都是我们做的。”
We changed humankind forever. They knew that, of course, that wasn't the case, but they were the perfect representation of what was happening. And they did drive and give credence to a lot of amazing changes that were happening. And I think also, I mean, just to begin, they do have their roots in kind of quite... the decades before they were born, which would include the war years, but going back into the 30s and even back into the 20s.
我们永远改变了人类。他们很清楚事实并非如此，但他们是当时正在发生的事情的完美化身。而且他们确实推动了许多正在发生的神奇变化，并为其提供了信誉。我也觉得——刚开始说起时——他们的根基实际上相当深厚……甚至在他们出生前的几十年，这就包括战争年代，但还要追溯到 30 年代甚至 20 年代。
So John was a big fan of Just William. I don't know, the thing in America, probably not, but it's kind of stories of this kind of raggedy schoolboy, and he has a gang of outlaws, and John was obsessed by it. And Paul's dad, you know, he kind of played all kinds of old traditional English music. And the influence of that on the Beatles tracks is kind of, of really evident. And also, I think it's interesting that they meet, John and Paul meet at a church fate. Neither of them were in any way religious. But it's a reminder that the world of England in the 50s is still one where, you know, you want to be a skiffle band. You still have to go and do it at a church fate because there isn't really anywhere else to have that kind of fun. That's the only gig. That's the only gig in town, really. Yeah. So, no, they come from a friend of mine said,
所以约翰是《威廉姆特辑》的超级粉丝。我不知道，这在美国可能是个什么东西，也许不是，但它讲述了一个衣衫褴褛的小学生的种种故事，他有一帮法外之徒，约翰对此痴迷不已。而保罗的父亲，你知道的，他弹奏各种古老的传统英国音乐。这些音乐对披头士歌曲的影响是显而易见的。而且，我觉得很有趣的是，约翰和保罗是在一个教堂游园会上相遇的。他们俩其实一点都不信教。但这提醒我们，50 年代的英国世界依然是一个这样的社会：如果你想组建一支斯基弗乐队，你仍然必须去教堂游园会上表演，因为实在没有其他地方可以获得那种乐趣。那是唯一的演出。那真的是城里唯一的演出。所以，不，他们来自……我一个朋友曾说过，
once Jimmy Vivino, my band leader, said, the Beatles single-handedly brought us from black and white to color, which I thought was an interesting way to look at it, which is they come from this very old tradition. Yeah. And they're well-schooled in English Music Hall, big band. Yeah, swing and all that. They have big ears.
我的乐队领队吉米·维维诺曾经说过：“披头士单枪匹马把我们从黑白时代带入了彩色时代。”我觉得这是一种很有趣的看法，也就是说，他们源自非常古老的传统。是的。而且他们在英国音乐厅曲艺、大乐队方面受过良好的训练。是的，摇摆乐等等。他们见多识广，
They're listening and hearing everything and soaking it all up. and later on it all comes out in the music. But obviously one of the things that they are listening to and are able to listen to perhaps in a way that lots of people elsewhere in England can't is the sounds of America because Liverpool is a port that is open to the Atlantic and ships that's still transport records are being brought over in ships and so they come to the port and the Beatles can access them.
他们倾听并吸收着所听到的一切，随后这一切都在他们的音乐中绽放。但显而易见的是，他们正在聆听、并且能够以英国其他很多地方的人所无法企及的方式聆听的事物之一，就是美国的音乐，因为利物浦是一个面向大西洋的港口，运送唱片的船只仍然通过海路运送过来，所以唱片被运到了港口，披头士就可以接触到它们。
Yeah, they can get Elvis, Gene Vincent, Buddy Holly. And black music. Yeah. Which is all, you know, they love all that. Yes. So when John and Paul meet at this church fate. The Walton Fet.
是的，他们能接触到猫王、吉恩·文森特、巴迪·霍利。还有黑人音乐。是的，这些都是……你知道的，他们非常喜欢所有这些。是的。所以当约翰和保罗在这次教堂游园会上相遇时。沃尔顿游园会。
The Walton Fate. John is singing a D-WOP song, Come Go With Me. Yeah. And he doesn't know the lyrics. And Paul doesn't know the lyrics either, but he knows the lyrics well enough to know that John can't remember them. Yeah. But the fact that they both know the lyrics,
沃尔顿游园会。约翰在唱一首嘟·沃普风格的歌曲《跟我走》。是的。而他记不清歌词了。保罗其实也不知道歌词，但他对歌词的熟悉程度足以听出约翰记不清了。是的。但他们两个都知道这首歌的歌词，
song is like a kind of masonic handshake between them. It's a sign that they have access to a kind of secret information. They are familiar with American music. And so the kind of the potential, the excitement, the drama of what is happening in America, you know, you said that the Beatles introduced color. But I think for the future Beatles, 1950s England is a monochrome country. Yes. And America is vibrant technicolor. Well, also, the war has been a very different experience. I don't need to tell you for people living in England. They've been bombed. They've seen their cities destroyed.
就像他们之间的一种共济会式的握手。这是一个信号，表明他们掌握了某种秘密信息。他们熟悉美国音乐。因此，美国正在发生的那些事情的潜力、兴奋感和戏剧性——你刚才说披头士引入了色彩，但对于未来的披头士成员来说，20 世纪 50 年代的英国是一个单色调的国家。是的。而美国则是充满活力的彩色。嗯，此外，战争也是一种截然不同的经历。对于生活在英国的人们来说，我不需要向你多说。他们的城市遭到轰炸，家园被毁。
They've paid a terrible price. They're still rationing. There's still war rationing. So they're growing up in a world where people are coming out of a days. And there's been a lot of privation. There's been a lot of difficulty. I also got into the Beatles in the 70s. And when I look back at the 60s, the 60s seemed an impossible distance from the Second World War.
他们付出了惨痛的代价。他们还在实行配给制。战时配给制依然存在。所以他们成长在一个人们正从懵懂中走出来的世界里。经历过许多艰难困苦，经历了许多坎坷。我也是在 70 年代迷上披头士的。当我回首 60 年代时，60 年代似乎与第二次世界大战有着不可逾越的距离。
But now you think, I mean, it's only 20 years. 20 years. I mean, it's so close. And when the Beatles are growing up, they are in a city that is cratered with kind of bomb damage. And as you say, you know, the Beatles are born in the war years. John is born during the Blitz. During a blitz. On Liverpool.
但现在想想，我的意思是，那才仅仅过去 20 年。20 年。我的意思是，时间是如此之近。当披头士在成长时，他们生活在一个布满炸弹坑洞的城市里。正如你所说，你知道，披头士出生在战争年代。约翰出生在大轰炸期间。在利物浦的大轰炸期间。
So George joins John and Paul. And they get joined by Stu Sondland. So Paul's the one who knows George, doesn't he? Introduces him and he plays raunchy on the top of a double-decker bus. Yeah, and that's enough. That's enough. You're in. Yeah.
后来乔治加入了约翰和保罗。斯图·萨特克利夫也加入了他们。是保罗认识乔治的，对吧？介绍了他，他在双层巴士的顶层弹奏了《Raunchy》。是的，这就够了。这就够了。你入选了。是的。
And then John's art school friend, Stu Sutcliffe, wins a prize for his art and spends it on a guitar. Well, John bullies him into, I don't know what he was, 80 pounds or 100 pounds or something. He bullies him into buying a bass, which Stu never really learns to play. But he's a cool-looking guy. He is. And I think that's an early sign that, yes, the music's important, but who we are, what we represent. And Stu is an artist. And Paul doesn't love this.
接着，约翰在艺术学校的朋友斯图·萨特克利夫赢了一笔艺术奖金，并把钱花在了一把吉他上。嗯，约翰怂恿他——我不知道那大概是 80 英镑还是 100 英镑左右。他怂恿斯图买了一把贝斯，而斯图其实从来没有真正学会弹奏。但他看起来很酷。他确实很酷。而且我认为这是一个早期的信号，那就是，音乐固然重要，但我们是谁、我们代表着什么同样重要。斯图是个艺术家。保罗并不太喜欢这样。
He really doesn't like Stu coming in because he can't play. And I think he's very close to John, which may have been a problem for Paul. Yes. And also there's Pete Best, a top hairdresser in later life. But at the time, the drummer. And so they all go off to Hamburg. And Hamburg equally, I mean, maybe even more than Liverpool, is obviously a city marked by the experience of the Second World War.
他真的很讨厌斯图加入，因为斯图不会弹琴。而且我认为他跟约翰走得太近了，这可能对保罗来说是个问题。是的。还有皮特·贝斯特，晚年成了一名顶级发型师。但在当时，他是乐队的鼓手。于是他们一起去了汉堡。汉堡同样——甚至可能比利物浦更甚——是一座深深打上第二次世界大战烙印的城市。
The British had flattened it. And of course, there were people there who had lived through the Nazi period. And it's always struck me that one of the things that is interesting about Hamburg in the Nazi period is that it's kind of notorious among the Nazi leadership for the enthusiasm of the young people who live there for American and English, jazz and swing. And it's a kind of rebellion against the ideals of the Hitler youth and all of that.
英国人曾将其夷为平地。当然，那里也有经历过纳粹时期的人。我一直觉得，关于纳粹时期的汉堡，有一件很有趣的事，那就是纳粹领导层对当地年轻人对美国和英国的爵士乐及摇摆乐的热情感到十分头疼，这也是他们臭名昭著的一点。这是对希特勒青年团理想及这一切的反叛。
And they grow their hair and they listen to jazz and they're particularly into black music. And this is a kind of, obviously, I mean, it's the anathema to everything that Nazism represents. And when the Beatles meet Astrid Kiersha and Klaus Foreman, who are kind of middle class intellectual Germans who are ashamed of the Nazi legacy and therefore are heirs to that tradition of seeing British and American music
他们留长发，听爵士乐，尤其痴迷黑人音乐。这显然……我的意思是，这是对纳粹主义所代表的一切的全然悖谬。当披头士遇到阿斯特丽德·基希赫和克劳斯·福尔曼时——他们是一群中产阶级德国知识分子，对纳粹的遗产感到羞耻，因此继承了将英美音乐视为自由和反抗纳粹主义表达的这一传统——
as something that is expressive of freedom and of opposition to Nazism. That's kind of one of the reasons why they all end up getting on so well. Well, they're also, they're bohemians. They're artists and outsiders looking in, and I think that's very attractive to John and Paul, especially, and George. They really like these people. They become good friends, and they're very much influenced by them. John calls them exes, doesn't he? Existentialists, and kind of France is the great influence.
这也是他们最终能够如此合得来的原因之一。嗯，他们也是波希米亚人。他们是艺术家和局外人，以旁观者的视角看待一切，我认为这非常吸引约翰和保罗，尤其是乔治。他们真的很喜欢这些人。他们成了好朋友，并且深受他们的影响。约翰管他们叫“存在主义者”，对吧？存在主义者，法国是他们的一大影响来源。
And in due course, it's Astridisha who will give the Beatles their kind of signature mop-top carts. which is influenced by these kind of European bohemian ideals. But just to reiterate, I mean, this is ultimately a kind of reaction against what the Nazis had represented and that kind of tradition. So there is a case for saying that the mop top is a kind of anti-Nazi hair cut. Do you think that's maybe going too far? I think you've pushed it way too far. Now I'm listening to all the early Beatles hits as anti-Hitler anthems.
不出一会儿，正是阿斯特丽德·基希赫赋予了披头士标志性的“拖把头”发型。而这种发型正是受到了欧洲波希米亚理想的影响。但还是要重申一下，这归根结底是对纳粹所代表的事物以及那种传统的一种反抗。所以有观点认为，这种“拖把头”其实是一种反纳粹的发型。你觉得这可能是有点过度解读了吗？我觉得你确实推得有点太过了。现在我都快把所有早期披头士的热门歌曲当成反希特勒赞歌来听了。
I do agree with you that there is. clearly and John said this Hamburg made them going to Hamburg made them because as Malcolm Gladwell pointed out they had to do their 100,000 hours and a billion. It always changes.
我确实同意你的看法，很明显——正如约翰所说，汉堡造就了他们。正如马尔科姆·格拉德威尔所指出，他们必须完成十万小时的练习，而标准总是在变。
I need a billion hours myself but it changes them the volume of work they have to do is incredible. They also need to entertain those crowds and they get very good at that. They get very good at winning getting people from peeking in the door
我自己也需要十亿个小时的练习，但这改变了他们。他们必须完成的工作量是惊人的。他们还需要取悦那些观众，并在这方面变得非常擅长。他们非常擅长赢得人心，让人们从门缝往里看，
to coming in to buying drinks. They do it... Oh, Mach Shao. Yeah, Mach Shao. They do it with the strength of their personalities and with their music, and they get honed into a diamond. And they're absolutely off their faces on amphetamins, aren't they?
到走进来买饮料。他们靠着……哦，马克·肖。是的，马克·肖。他们靠着个性的力量和音乐做到这一点，他们被打磨得像钻石一样耀眼。而且他们当时绝对嗑了安非他命，对吧？
Prelleys. Yeah. Yeah. They're on these pills that enable them to play and play and play and play. They're living in, I think they're living in, I think they share a wall with a theater. So they're living in conditions that aren't safe. Isn't that where George is his virginity? And all the Beatles are kind of on bunks watching him or whatever.
普雷莱斯。是的。是的。他们靠着这些药丸，能够不停地、不停地、不停地演奏。他们住在——我想他们住在一个剧院的隔壁。所以他们住在不安全的环境里。乔治不就是在那儿失去童贞的吗？所有的披头士成员好像都挤在双层床上看着他或者别的什么。
I mean, it's all very quite squalid, but kind of quite, but properly rock and roll. at a time when in America and England still more so, the music is kind of stopping being quite so rock and roll. Yeah, I mean, there's this period, you know, I think Chuck Berry violates the man act and has to be, I think he goes to jail or is, it's a scandal. Jerry Lee Lewis has his scandal. He definitely has a scandal.
我的意思是，这一切都非常肮脏，但又相当摇滚。当时在美英两国，尤其是英国，音乐已经开始不再那么摇滚了。是的，我的意思是，在这个时期，你知道，查克·贝里违反了曼恩法案，不得不——我想他入狱了或者怎么的，这是一个丑闻。杰里·李·刘易斯也有他的丑闻。他确实有丑闻。
Buddy Holly dies. A big bopper. The big bopper and Ritchie Valens. And Elvis gets drafted, of course. Elvis gets drafted. Which the Beatles very narrowly avoid because National Service, which is a thing here in England in the 50s, and it gets stopped just before they would have become eligible for it.
巴迪·霍利去世了。大博普。大博普和里奇·瓦伦斯。当然，猫王应征入伍了。猫王应征入伍了。披头士非常侥幸地避开了这一点，因为英国在50年代曾实行国民服役制度，而就在他们快要符合服役年龄之前，这项制度被取消了。
And we would all agree that the Beatles would not have done well in national service. You would not have been good. Well, because they, it's kind of interesting that when they're driving out to Ambo for the first time, they go past Arnhem, which is a bridge too far, kind of disastrous, British lose, lots of people there. And the story is that John refuses to get out of the van and go and look at the graves, and already perhaps a sense there that war in its totality is something to be rejected. And that, of course, will become a massive theme for John's music and ideals later in life. But I mean, it might be there right from the beginning. Although apparently when he's
我们都会同意，披头士如果去服国民服役是不会有什么好结果的。你们不会表现好的。嗯，因为他们——很有趣的是，当他们第一次开车去汉堡时，他们路过了阿纳姆，那是一座过于遥远的桥，可以说是灾难性的，英国人输了，很多人死在那里。传说约翰拒绝下车去墓地看看，或许当时就已经有一种意识：必须彻底拒绝战争。当然，这后来成为约翰音乐和理想中的一个巨大主题。但我的意思是，这种意识可能从一开始就存在。尽管显然当他在
on the stage in Hamburg, he's always shouting out in English, you know, crouts, we beat you in the war kind of stuff. So as always with the Beatles, it's never, there's always a kind of creative tension. Yeah, John, even then is walking that line between he's goading thugs in a Hamburg crowd to attack him and then relying on security to handle it or a bouncer or someone, walking that line between I dare you to hit me and
汉堡的舞台上时，他总是用英语大喊大叫，你知道，‘德国佬，我们在战争中打败了你们’之类的话。所以，和披头士的许多事情一样，这里面总有一种创造性的张力。是的，约翰即使在那个时候，也游走在这样一条线上：他一方面在汉堡的人群中挑衅暴徒来攻击他，然后又依靠安保人员或保镖来处理局面，游走在‘我敢你打我’的边缘，以及
I think quite a few of the bouncers only kind of had one arm or one leg or whatever because they were
我想很多保镖大概只有一条胳膊或一条腿之类的，因为他们在战争中致残了，所以
kind of maimed in the war so yeah quite a I mean quite a crucible I guess and explains a lot
可以说是经历了一场严峻的考验，这也很大程度上解释了
about the kind of band that the Beatles in due course became you know the comeback from Hamburg they go
披头士后来成为什么样的乐队，你知道，他们从汉堡回来，又
back to Hamburg then they come back to Liverpool again and by this point so 1961 1962
回到了汉堡，接着又回到了利物浦，到了这个时候——1961年到1962年，
they're starting to a stand themselves as the biggest name in Liverpool. When they come back to Liverpool, there are people who think that they're a German band because they hear that they've come from Hamburg. So, and they're so polished. I mean, they're a completely different act. I think on the scene in Liverpool, there were bands that didn't take them seriously.
他们开始确立自己作为利物浦头号乐队的地位。当他们回到利物浦时，有些人以为他们是一支德国乐队，因为听说他们是从汉堡来的。而且他们经过了精雕细琢。我的意思是，他们成了一支完全不同的乐队。我认为在利物浦的音乐圈里，有一些乐队并没有把他们放在眼里。
Then they come back from Hamburg and they've had this education and they've been transmuted. They call their leather. And they're down in the cavern and the ceiling is dripping sweat from excited girls who are there in their lunch hour. And it's very fetid and exciting and rock and roll. And it is on the 9th of November 1961 that a key figure in the story of the Beatles finds his way down the steps into the cavern. And that, of course, is Brian Epstein. Yeah. You know, when the colonel finds Elvis, the colonel is very well established as a guy who could take over Elvis's contract. It should be pointed out that Brian Epstein is not that figure. He's working at, I believe, his family's record store, record shop.
然后他们从汉堡归来，接受了这种历练并完成了蜕变。他们穿着皮衣。他们在洞穴俱乐部里演出，天花板上滴落着兴奋的女歌迷们的汗水，她们利用午休时间赶来。这里非常闷热、刺激且充满摇滚气息。正是在1961年11月9日，披头士故事中的一个关键人物走进了洞穴俱乐部的台阶。这个人当然就是布赖恩·爱泼斯坦。是的。你知道，当上校找到猫王时，上校作为一个可以接手猫王合同的人已经名声在外。需要指出的是，布赖恩·爱泼斯坦并非那样的人物。他当时在——我相信是在他家族的唱片店里工作。
He's never managed anybody. No. And he sees this group that really just fascinates him. and particularly John because Brian is gay and he definitely I think has a thing for John doesn't he? Yeah but he kind of
他从来没有管理过任何人。没有。但他看到了这个真正令他着迷的乐队，尤其是约翰，因为布赖恩是同性恋，而且他绝对——我觉得他对约翰有意思，对吧？是的，但他有点
immediately picks up on the fact that this band is amazing and decides that he is going to try and get them a record contract and although he's never managed anyone he does kind of have links with the music industry and he's middle class as opposed to the Beatles
立刻察觉到这支乐队非常了不起，并决定设法为他们争取一份唱片合约。尽管他从未管理过任何人，但他确实与音乐界有一些联系，而且他是中产阶级，与披头士的
so working class and in England in the early 60s that is massively important and it means that he can make contact with other middle class people among whom is a producer here in Abbey Road called George Martin. And so famously, Brian Epstein hawks the Beatles around all kinds of record companies and they turn him down. Decker famously, you know, guitar groups are on their way out. But George Martin basically is the last port of calls, parlophone at EMI and he says yeah okay I'll give them a go but it's um George Martin is still not entirely convinced is he no I mean not one point I would make I think should be
工人阶级背景形成对比。在60年代初的英国，这一点至关重要，这意味着他能够接触到其他中产阶级人士，其中就包括阿比路的一位名叫乔治·马丁的制作人。众所周知，布赖恩·爱泼斯坦带着披头士跑遍了各种唱片公司，但都被拒绝了。迪卡唱片有一句名言：‘吉他乐队已经过时了。’但乔治·马丁基本上是最后一站，即EMI旗下的帕洛风唱片，他说‘好吧，我给他们一次机会’，但是——乔治·马丁当时仍然不是完全确信，对吧？不，我的意思是，我要提出的一点是
made is that in addition to all of their amazing qualities the Beatles have uh insane luck they have incredible luck because many people might have approached them and said I think I could represent you. Brian Epstein is unusual. He's someone who really loves them for them. He's someone who really respects them as artists, and he wants to take care of them. Now, remember, this is the music business.
除了他们所有惊人的品质之外，披头士还有着疯狂的运气，他们有难以置信的运气，因为很多人可能会接近他们并说‘我想我可以代表你’。布赖恩·爱泼斯坦与众不同。他是那种真正因为他们本身而喜爱他们的人。他是真正作为艺术家尊重他们、并想要照顾他们的人。现在请记住，这是音乐界。
That doesn't happen. Then who does he take them to? Who do they hook up with George Martin? The people they meet early on are the essential people, and it's some kind of hobbit tale where they meet the exact right person at the exact right time. It's all hotting up, and I don't think I can take the attention right now. I need a bit of a breather.
没有这种事。那他把他们带去见谁了？他们和谁搭上了线？乔治·马丁？他们早期遇到的人都是关键人物，这简直就像个霍比特人的故事，他们在确切的正确时间遇到了确切的对的人。局势越来越紧张，我现在简直无法承受这种关注了。我需要喘口气。
So let's have a quick break. When you're flying Emirates business class, sipping your favorite cocktail at our onboard lounge, you'll see that your vacation isn't really over until your flight is over. Fly, Emirates, fly better. Get no frills delivered. Shop the same in-store prices online and enjoy unlimited delivery with PC Express Pass. Get your first year for $2.50 a month.
所以我们休息一下。当您乘坐阿联酋航空商务舱，在我们的机上酒廊品尝您最喜爱的鸡尾酒时，您会发现，只有当航班结束时，您的假期才真正结束。搭乘阿联酋航空，飞得更好。享受物超所值的配送服务。在线享受与店内同等的价格，并通过 PC Express Pass 享受无限配送。首年每月仅需 2.5 万加元。
Learn more at pceexpress.ca. Ella McKay, coming to theaters December 12th. Your father's here. Why? A heartwarming new comedy from James L. Brooks. I'm a different person. I have never in my life out this way about any other woman. Jesus! I wasn't counting your mother! It's a perfect holiday comedy about an imperfect family.
访问 pceexpress.ca 了解更多信息。《埃拉·麦凯》，12 月 12 日全国影院上映。你父亲来了。为什么？詹姆士·L·布鲁克斯带来的温馨全新喜剧。我是个不同的人。我这辈子从来没有对其他女人有过这种感觉。天哪！我没算上你母亲！这是一部关于一个不完美家庭的完美节日喜剧。
You can use a screen. Starring Emma Mackey, Jamie Lee Curtis, Camel Nanjani, Iowa Debrie, with Albert Brooks and Woody Harrelson. You should do that every afternoon. Ella McKay. Hello, welcome back to The Rest of History. I am with Conan O'Brien, and we are talking Beatles. So George Martin hadn't really been a music producer. He'd been a producer of comedy shows.
你可以使用屏幕。由艾玛·麦基、杰米·李·库蒂斯、库梅尔·南贾尼、阿尤·埃德比利联袂主演，阿尔伯特·布鲁克斯和伍迪·哈里森参演。你每天下午都应该这么做。埃拉·麦凯。你好，欢迎收看《历史的其余部分》。我是柯南·奥布莱恩，我们正在聊甲壳虫乐队。所以乔治·马丁其实并不是一个音乐制作人。他曾是一名喜剧节目的制作人。
The Goon Show. The Goon Show. And the Beatles really appreciate that, but it also means that George Martin can appreciate their zany mop-top humour. So George Harrison famously saying he didn't like George Martin's tie. And George Martin not being unduly offended by that. And so he decides actually that the Beatles have got something, that they've got personality as well as musical ability.
《疯狂秀》。《疯狂秀》。甲壳虫乐队非常欣赏这一点，但这也意味着乔治·马丁能够欣赏他们古怪的西瓜头幽默。所以乔治·哈里森曾坦言他不喜欢乔治·马丁的领带，这已经成了名言。而乔治·马丁并没有因此而感到过分冒犯。因此他最终决定，甲壳虫乐队确实有些东西，他们除了音乐才华之外，还有个性。
But there is one member of the Beatles. he doesn't rate. And Stu Sutton, by this point, has died of a brain hemorrhage. But Pete Bess is still on the scene. And George Martin says to Brian, he's got to go. And so the final piece in the jigsaw puzzle now slots into place, namely Ringo. Yeah, yeah. Who you've also met.
但甲壳虫乐队里有一个成员是他看不上的。斯图·萨特此时已经死于脑出血。但皮特·贝斯特还在场。乔治·马丁对布莱恩说，他必须离开。于是，拼图的最后一块现在落入了正确的位置，也就是林戈。对，对。这也是你见过的人。
And you said that you gave him a hug once and his body is now made of teak. Yes. I've met Ringo a number of times. And one time I gave him a hug, and I thought he's carved out of a very dense tropical wood. This man works out, I think obsessively, he just hit his 85th birthday, and I think he could take both of us in a fight. He's an incredible shape. Which is amazing because Ringo was born in absolutely the poorest part, the most bomb damaged part of Liverpool, and grew up repeatedly being ill. always in hospital, kind of missed out on school and all kinds of things.
你说你曾经拥抱过他，他的身体现在就像柚木做的一样。是的。我见过林戈很多次。有一次我拥抱了他，我想他的身体就像是用一种非常坚密的温带木材雕刻出来的。这个人似乎有强迫症般地锻炼，他刚刚迎来 85 岁生日，我觉得他在打架时能同时打赢我们两个。他的状态好得不可思议。这太神奇了，因为林戈出生在利物浦绝对最贫困、遭受轰炸最严重的地区，而且在成长过程中屡次生病。总是在医院里，几乎错过了学校和各种各样的事情。
But by the time the Beatles approach him, has established himself as the best drummer in Liverpool. And again, it's the kind of, it's the humor and the personality. Ringo completely gels with them. And George Martin has actually brought a session drummer in for their, to record their first single. And his name is Andy White. Andy White, yes.
但当甲壳虫乐队接近他时，他已经确立了自己作为利物浦最佳鼓手的地位。同样，这也是那种幽默感和个性。林戈与他们完全合拍。乔治·马丁实际上为他们录制第一首单曲时带了一位录音室鼓手。他的名字叫安迪·怀特。安迪·怀特，是的。
What's interesting is that people have always wondered, or theorize that Pete Best is too good-looking and maybe Paul is jealous and they edge him out. But it's been pretty much conclusively proved that he was not a good timekeeper. He couldn't really keep time. And Ringo could play all these different beats, these Latin beats that later on show up in so many Beatles records. So he was the right guy at the right time.
有趣的是，人们一直想知道或推测皮特·贝斯特太帅了，也许保罗很嫉妒，所以他们把他挤走了。但事实已基本确凿，他不是一个好的时间掌控者。他真的很难把握节奏。而林戈可以演奏所有这些不同的节奏，这些拉丁节奏后来出现在许多甲壳虫乐队的唱片中。所以他是对的时间对的人。
And so how would you rate Ringo as a drummer? Oh, I think he's spectacular. And a lot of top drummers now give it up to Ringo. His feel, he's minimal. And there's a great thing you can see on YouTube, which is if Keith Moon had been the Beatles drummer, if John Bonham had been the Beatles drummer. And you listen to them and you're like,
那么你会如何评价林戈作为鼓手的水平呢？哦，我觉得他太棒了。现在很多顶级鼓手都对林戈赞不绝口。他的乐感，他是极简主义的。你在 YouTube 上可以看到一个很棒的视频，那就是如果基思·穆恩是甲壳虫乐队的鼓手，如果约翰·博纳姆是甲壳虫乐队的鼓手。当你听他们的演奏时，你会觉得……
yeah, that wouldn't be the same. It wouldn't work. So is he Gene Krupa or Buddy Rich? No, he's not. he's the best possible drummer for the Beatles yeah and actually so there's um the the the footage that you can see in the background is from a new version of the anthology documentary series um out on disney and in these episodes there's amazing footage of wringo drumming you can completely see what he is giving the Beatles so the as i say the final piece in the jigsaw puzzle is there yeah
是的，那就不一样了。那样行不通。所以他是吉恩·克鲁帕还是巴迪·里奇？不，他不是。他是甲壳虫乐队最好的鼓手，对，事实上，嗯，你在背景中可以看到的 footage 是来自迪士尼播出的全新版本的选集纪录片系列，在这些剧集中有林戈打鼓的精彩画面，你可以完全看出他为甲壳虫乐队贡献了什么，所以正如我所说，拼图的最后一块就在那里，是的。
and so their first single love me do comes out in Britain, which is 17. Brian's shop has bought in box loads of it, craze of the stuff, flogged it across Liverpool. But it's still not obvious that they are going to completely change. everything. And it's when they then turn up to record their first album, Please Please Me. Last night I said these were to my girl. I know you never even try, girl. Come on, come on, come on, please, please, please, we will.
他们的第一首单曲《Love Me Do》在英国发行，那是17号。布莱恩的店里进货了一箱又一箱，这东西成了狂热追捧的对象，在利物浦卖得火热。但很显然，他们还没有完全改变一切。当他们去录制他们的第一张专辑《Please Please Me》时，情况就不同了。昨晚我对我的女孩说这些。我知道你甚至从来没有尝试过，女孩。来吧，来吧，来吧，求求你，求求你，求求你，我们会做到的。
George Martin famously says, gentlemen, you just made your first number one. The sense that this is something special. And one of the key things is that they're not just recording covers. So we should probably just talk about that. Because you said earlier, this is something that marks them out as distinctive. Yeah.
乔治·马丁有一句名言：先生们，你们刚刚创造了第一首冠军单曲。这种感觉表明这是一件特别的事情。关键点之一是他们不只是在录制翻唱歌曲。所以我们大概应该讨论一下这一点。因为你刚才说过，这是让他们与众不同的标志。是的。
But it is really unusual, isn't it? It's revolutionary. It's unheard of. So what John and Paul were always interested, in almost the brill-building tradition of being songwriters. And Paul used to think about being a songwriter, even if it meant he wasn't the one performing the song. They just thought about songwriting.
但这真的很不寻常，不是吗？这具有革命性。这是前所未闻的。约翰和保罗一直感兴趣的，几乎是 Brill Building 传统式的词曲创作。保罗过去常常考虑成为一名词曲创作者，即使这意味着他不是演唱这首歌的人。他们只是考虑词曲创作。
They were working on it for a long time. They're writing things, but not of the quality that they'd later have. But then this moment comes when they've done Love Me Do, It's so-so. It's so-so. You listen to it now and you think, I don't know what all the excitement was. And the truth is, it was number 17. Yeah.
他们为此努力了很长时间。他们在写东西，但质量没有他们后来达到的那么高。但随后这个时刻来了，他们完成了《Love Me Do》，马马虎虎。马马虎虎。你现在听它，会想，我不知道之前有什么好激动的。事实是，它排名第 17 位。是的。
Brian probably helped them, boost them up the charts by buying records himself. So they really need to make it. John has a song that's in the vein of, he's thinking of a Roy Orbison song. And it's written, it's a very slow kind of Roy Orbison ballad. Come on, come on, come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
布莱恩可能通过自己买唱片来帮助他们提升排行榜名次。所以他们真的很需要成功。约翰有一首歌，有点像罗伊·奥尔ビ森的风格，他脑子里想着一首罗伊·奥尔ビ森的歌。这首歌写好了，是一首非常慢的罗伊·奥尔ビ森式的民谣。来吧，来吧，来吧。来吧。来吧。来吧。
Please, please. Oh, yeah. My guy please you. And they're working on it. It's not coming together. And then they decide, let's pick up the tempo. And they have it. And that's their first number one.
求求你，求求你。哦，是的。我的伙计请你。他们正在创作。进展并不顺利。然后他们决定，加快节奏。他们成功了。那是他们的第一首冠军单曲。
The Stones, Dominic's not here, but I wish I could say this to his face. The Stones are doing covers down in London. They hear that there's this group up in Liverpool that's making records, which the stones are not doing, and they're writing them themselves, and they're flabbergasted, and I think, skeptical. And inspired in the long run. In the long run. Yeah, it took them a while, Dominic, it took them a while.
滚石乐队，多米尼克不在这里，但我希望我能当面这样对他说。滚石乐队在伦敦做翻唱。他们听说利物浦有个乐队在出唱片，而滚石乐队没有这样做，而且他们自己写歌，他们惊呆了，我想，也是怀疑的。从长远来看，受到了启发。从长远来看。是的，他们花了一段时间，多米尼克，他们花了一段时间。
But they don't do badly either. No, they do just fine. But the quickening up the pace, the harmonies, the shaking of the hair, the twisting and the shouting, when the album goes up, out and then she loves you and a succession of singles and the live performances and girls start screaming yeah and they start kind of pushing at cordons of policemen and the Beatles have mentioned they like jelly beans and so they start hurling jelly beans yeah george had said an interview i like these uh whatever they're called jelly beans and um from then on he's pelted with them and so quite dangerous because they, you know, you could take out an eye or two.
不过他们的表现也不差。不，他们做得很好。但随着节奏加快，和声响起，头发甩动，扭动和呐喊，当专辑热卖、推出接着是《She Loves You》，以及接连不断的单曲和现场演出，女孩们开始尖叫“耶”，她们开始推挤警察的警戒线，甲壳虫乐队曾提到他们喜欢果冻豆，于是大家开始向他们猛砸果冻豆。乔治曾在一次采访中说，我喜欢这些……不管它们叫什么名字，果冻豆。从那以后，他就一直被果冻豆砸中，这其实挺危险的，因为你知道的，一不小心就会戳瞎一两只眼睛。
Yeah. He should have mentioned, George should have mentioned a softer treat. Maybe a marshmallow. Jelly babies, perhaps. Yeah. But this is a kind of explosion of public teenage female joy of a kind that no one has ever seen before. And I guess it's explained in part by the charisma and the music of the Beatles. But it's also explained by.
对啊。他本该提议，乔治本该提议一种更软的零食。也许是棉花糖。或者果冻宝贝糖。对啊。但这是公众对少女喜悦的一种爆发，这种狂热是前所未见的。我想这部分可以由甲壳虫乐队的魅力和音乐来解释。但它也可以解释为……
by, you know, to put it in Marxist terms, the fact that for the first time teenage girls have spending money and leisure time. Yeah. And so you see there again, you talked about how lucky the Beatles are, that they are riding this crest of this wave of growing material prosperity that is kind of giving birth to the idea of the teenager as a consumer. Yeah. So another way in which they get incredibly lucky, the timing is spectacular because, as you say, if this had been 10 years earlier, I don't think this maybe could have happened, but they're at the right time, perfect time where a whole group of teenagers can express
用马克思主义的话来说，是因为青春期女孩第一次有了零花钱和闲暇时间。对啊。所以你看，正如你之前说的，甲壳虫乐队是多么幸运，他们正乘着物质繁荣不断增长的浪潮，而这股浪潮催生了“青少年作为消费者”的概念。所以他们极其幸运的另一点在于，时机简直好得惊艳，因为正如你所说，如果这一切早发生10年，我认为可能就不会发生了，但他们恰逢其时，在一个完美的时机，让整群青少年能够表达……
a different opinion than their parents, which teenagers want to do, they want to make something theirs, and here are these four perfect people with great music, and they can elect to spend their money on these records, and they can have their favorite beetle, and it starts to fuel this mania. And do you think the fact that all the bands and the singers that we've talked about up till now who influenced the Beatles have been male, but actually the Beatles are really, really into female groups as well? Yes. Do you think that's kind of contributory factor to their popularity with specifically female audience? In his book, Ian Leslie wrote this fantastic book that I absolutely love. I think it's the best Beatles book that's been written in quite a while.
与父母不同的意见，这是青少年渴望做的事，他们想要创造属于自己的东西，而这里正好有四个完美的人和美妙的音乐，他们可以选择把钱花在这些唱片上，他们可以拥有自己最喜欢的乐队成员，这开始助长这种狂热。你觉得，到目前为止我们谈论过的、对甲壳虫乐队产生影响的所有乐队和歌手都是男性的事实，但实际上甲壳虫乐队也真的非常喜欢女子组合吗？是的。你认为这也是他们特别受女性观众欢迎的一个促成因素吗？伊恩·莱斯利（Ian Leslie）在他的书中写过一本我非常喜欢的精彩书籍。我认为这是近来写得最好的甲壳虫乐队的书。
So John and Paul, isn't it? John and Paul. And in it, he, he points out something I hadn't really thought of, which is a lot of early Beatles music is influenced by doo-wop groups. If someone just told me that without me thinking about it and say, well, that's stupid. But no, it's not. It's true. They are performing a lot of stuff by male doo-wop groups and also female groups. And I think they are just going for what's the best music. And they are also very interested in getting the vocals right. So they play their own instruments, but I think their secret weapon is their vocal ability. Yeah, the harmonies.
所以是约翰和保罗，对吧？约翰和保罗。在书中，他指出了一点我之前没怎么想过的事，那就是早期甲壳虫乐队的很多音乐都受到了嘟·瓦普（doo-wop）组合的影响。如果有人不假思索地直接告诉我这一点，我会觉得这太蠢了。但其实不然，这是真的。他们翻唱了很多男性嘟·瓦普组合以及女子组合的作品。而且我认为他们只是在追求最好的音乐。他们也非常注重把声部和声唱好。所以他们演奏自己的乐器，但我认为他们的秘密武器是他们的演唱能力。对，他们的和声。
The harmonies and Everly Brothers, I think were a huge influence on them. But yes, they will play, I mean, Ringo sings boys and doesn't, they don't. Yes, so the Sherell's number. They don't change. It would be so easy to say girls. It would be so easy to change it, and they don't. And it's a little strange, but it's fantastic. And so, yes, there is, they're not overly concerned.
和声，还有埃弗利兄弟（Everly Brothers），我认为对他们有巨大的影响。没错，他们会演奏，我是说，林戈（Ringo）演唱了《Boys》，他们不是……是的，还有薛瑞尔斯（The Shirelles）的曲子。他们没有改歌词。把歌词改成“girls”其实轻而易举。要改掉它简直易如反掌，但他们没有。这有点奇怪，但太棒了。所以，是的，他们并不是过度关注……
with gender. They're not overly concerned with, you know, no, no, we've got to stick to this image or that image. They're just going where the best music is. Now, I know what Dominic would say about the secret of their popularity is also the fact that they are just edgy enough. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So they say she loves you, yeah, yeah, yeah. So they say, she loves you, yeah, yeah, yeah, rather than as Paul's father. thought they should have sung. She loves you. Yes, yes, yes. Yes. But they're not going too far. So the kind of the prelly popping and the, you know, all the kind of Hamburg stuff is
性别问题。他们并不过度纠结于，你知道的，“不，不，我们必须坚持这种形象或那种形象”。他们只是奔向最好的音乐所在的地方。现在，我知道多米尼克会怎么说他们的受欢迎秘诀了，那就是他们还带点叛逆的边缘感。对，对，对。所以他们唱“she loves you, yeah, yeah, yeah”。所以他们唱的是“she loves you, yeah, yeah, yeah”，而不是像保罗的父亲所认为的那样他们应该唱的——“She loves you. Yes, yes, yes.”是的。但他们也没有走得太过头。所以那种早期的流行泡泡糖风格以及所有汉堡时期的那种……
being kind of slightly pushed to one side. And Brian has put them in suits by this point. And in the long run, it's the stones who will play the part of the kind of the bad boys. Yeah. The Beatles are just edgy enough, but no more so. Right. And they, you know, they famously, they play at the raw variety. show, and John has his witty quip.
都被稍微推到了一边。到这个时候，布赖恩已经让他们穿上了西装。从长远来看，滚石乐队（The Stones）将扮演那种“坏男孩”的角色。对。甲壳虫乐队恰到好处地带有一点边缘感，但又不过火。没错。而且众所周知，他们在皇家综艺秀（Royal Variety Show）上演出，约翰说了那个机智诙谐的俏皮话：
For our last number, I'd like to ask your help. The people in the cheaper seats clap your hands. And the rest of you, if you just rattle your jewelry. Which Noel Coward was hated that. I don't know why I remember that, but Noel Coward thought that was atrocious. Did he? And this brings up, that performance brings up something really interesting, which is the Beatles represent this new thing which is class is irrelevant and they are playing in
“接下来的这首歌，我想请大家帮个忙。坐在廉价座位上的人请鼓掌。至于其余的人，请摇晃你们的珠宝就行了。”诺埃尔·科沃德（Noel Coward）极其讨厌这个。我不知道为什么我记得这个，但诺埃尔·科沃德认为这简直太糟了。是吗？而这引发了，这场表演引发了一个非常有趣的问题，那就是甲壳虫乐队代表了一种新事物，也就是阶级不再重要，他们正在……
front of the queen in a royal performance and John makes this joke that is very much about class and Noel Coward I think got upset people thought well this is how could he I mean some people were really taken aback by that but they are four working class guys who don't change their accents. They don't adopt James Mason accents when they make it big. They have thick Liverpoolian accents and they never try to change it. They don't work on their addiction or anything. Yes, they wear the suits because they are ambitious. They're extremely ambitious and they will do what it takes to get to the top. So, I mean, it's great to be number one in Britain to be going around all these kind of market towns and selling out concerts and
女王面前进行皇家演出，而约翰开了这个非常具有阶级色彩的玩笑，诺埃尔·科沃德我想对此很不高兴，人们当时想，怎么能这样——我是说，有些人确实对此感到非常震惊——但他们是四个不改变口音的工人阶级小伙。他们成名后也没有模仿詹姆斯·梅森（James Mason）式的口音。他们操着浓重的利物浦口音，而且从不试图改变它。他们没有刻意练习发音什么的。是的，他们穿上西装是因为他们有野心。他们野心勃勃，为了登上顶峰他们会不惜一切代价。所以，在英国排名第一、在各个集镇巡演、门票售罄、举办……
headlining and having repeated number ones and all kinds of things. But they have been massively influenced by American music and for people in Britain to break it in America is the ultimate dream. And British artists have not succeeded in making it in America at all. And Brian is kind of trying to boost their career in America, but it's not really working. And America is distracted, apart from anything else, by, you know, America has its trauma because when the Beatles' second album with the Beatles comes out in Britain, it's the same day that Kennedy is shot in Dallas. And it is often said that that plunges America into a state of kind of mourning and bereavement that leaves them kind of wanting almost to be cheered up. Do you think
头牌演出、接连不断地夺得冠军以及各种成就，这当然很棒。但他们深受美国音乐的影响，对于英国人来说，在美国取得成功才是终极梦想。而且英国艺术家此前在美国根本没有成功过。布赖恩一直在努力推动他们在英国以外的美国市场的发展，但并没有真正奏效。而且美国正被其他事情分心，除其他原因外，美国正经历着创伤——就在甲壳虫乐队在英国发行第二张专辑《With the Beatles》的同一天，肯尼迪在达拉斯遇刺了。人们常说，这让美国陷入了一种哀悼和悲痛的状态，以至于他们几乎迫切渴望得到一些慰藉。你认为……
there's anything in that? Yeah, again, I mean, it's heresy to use the word luck with an assassination and a day that that's awful. But I will say, you know, I do these history experiments in my head sometimes. What if the Beatles had been booked November 30th on the Ed Sullivan show? What if they had been booked in December? It's too soon. So they end up going to the U.S. in February.
这其中有什么说法吗？是的，话说回来，在暗杀事件和这样一个糟糕的日子里使用“运气”这个词简直是异端邪说。但我得说，你知道的，我有时会在脑海里做这样的历史实验：如果甲壳虫乐队被预约在11月30日登上《埃德·沙利文秀》（The Ed Sullivan Show）会怎么样？如果他们被预约在12月会怎么样？那就太早了。所以他们最终在2月份去了美国。
In February, by which point I want to hold. your hand is number one. And it's crucial that they go there with that single already number one. So that they're not going as, you know, supplicants, they're going as stars. This is one of those moments where Paul has subsequently said, we knew to wait until we had number one hits in the U.S. to go over. And if you look into it, I don't think it holds up. I think that Ed Sullivan had been flying in Europe. His plane has a stopover, I think, in, I don't know if he's in Sweden or he's someplace. And he sees screaming fans. And he says, what's that all about? And he says, it's this group from England, the Beatles. These youngsters from Liverpool, who call themselves the Beatles. Yeah. And so the booking is made before the Beatles have hit number one in America.
到了2月份，那时《I Want to Hold Your Hand》已经是冠军单曲了。至关重要的是，他们带着这首已经是冠军的单曲去那里。这样他们去的时候就不是作为摇尾乞怜的人，而是作为巨星。这是保罗后来提到的那些时刻之一，他曾说：“我们知道要等到我们在美国有了冠军单曲再过去。”但如果你深入研究一下，我觉得这个说法站不住脚。我认为当时埃德·沙利文一直在欧洲飞行。他的飞机中转了，我想，我不知道他是在瑞典还是在某个地方。他看到了尖叫的粉丝。然后他问：“那是什么？”别人告诉他：“这是来自英国的一个组合，甲壳虫乐队。这些自称为甲壳虫乐队的利物浦年轻人。”对。所以演出预订其实是在甲壳虫乐队在美国夺得冠军之前就定下的。
Again, the timing is perfect. But again, it's not just luck, but luck plays a big part in it. So they landed at JFK and there's huge press attention and there are crowds of screaming girls. Which surprises them. It does. And it obviously surprises the US media as well. There's kind of incredible footage in the anthology documentary of them arriving outside the hotel with girls just hurling themselves at the window. And it's like they're in a zombie film.
又一次，时机完美无缺。但这也并非纯靠运气，不过运气确实在其中扮演了重要角色。所以当他们降落 在肯尼迪国际机场（JFK）时，受到了巨大的媒体关注，现场挤满了尖叫的女孩。这让他们感到很意外。确实如此。这显然也让美国媒体大吃一惊。在《精选集》（Anthology）纪录片里，有一些不可思议的镜头，记录了他们抵达酒店外时，女孩们直接朝窗户猛扑过去的场景。那感觉就像他们身处僵尸电影中一样。
And it's like the kind of zombie plague has crossed the Atlantic from Britain and now it's arrived in New York. And the screaming and the hysteria becomes part of the story, doesn't it? And it is present when it is present. the Beatles appear on the Ed Sullivan show. Yeah. And that show, I think, is still the second most viewed program in U.S. history. Yeah, I think some reality show has the number one spot, I believe, someone eating cockroaches. About two years ago, Paul McCartney released pictures that he took because all of them had cameras.
这就好像某种僵尸瘟疫已经从英国跨越大西洋，如今抵达了纽约。尖叫声和狂热情绪成了故事的一部分，不是吗？当甲壳虫乐队出现在《埃德·沙利文秀》上时，这种狂热也随之呈现。对。而且那个节目，我认为至今仍是美国历史上收视率第二高的节目。对，我想某个真人秀节目占据了第一的位置，好像是有人在吃蟑螂。大约两年前，保罗·麦卡特尼（Paul McCartney）公布了自己当年拍摄的照片，因为他们所有人都有相机。
They had given cameras. So Paul called it the eyes of the storm because it's all of them. but he took pictures constantly and I had a chance to interview him about it and he was talking about being in the center of all that and how surprised they were yeah and he was just taking all these photos of a lot of them are just people losing their minds and staring at them and you know I think it was George who later said we just became an excuse for people to lose their minds yeah People wanted to lose their minds. They needed some kind of fuse or trigger, and this group shows up, and yes, the music's great, and yes, they have these incredible personalities, but it's something completely new when everyone says it is time to go insane.
他们当时都拿到了相机。所以保罗把这组照片命名为《风暴之眼》（The Eyes of the Storm），因为全都是他们……但他一直在不停地拍照，我曾有机会就此采访过他，他谈到置身于那所有狂热的正中心时，他们是多么惊讶。是的，他当时拍了好多照片，其中很多只是人们失去理智、死死盯着他们的画面。你知道的，我想后来是乔治说过：“我们只是成了人们失去理智的借口。”对。人们渴望失去理智。他们需要某种导火索或触发点，而这个乐队出现了，是的，音乐很棒，是的，他们有着令人难以置信的个性，但这是一种全新事物，当所有人都认为“是时候疯狂了”的时候。
Yeah, and so that's something that the Beatles are introducing to America, but obviously for the Beatles as well, going to America is a kind of pilgrimage, because this is where the music that they have most loved and have been most inspired comes from. from. And we've said they're particularly influenced by black American music. And so one of the issues that comes up in in 1964, when they're going on tour around the US, is the question of will they play in segregated stadiums? Because that is still very much a thing. Civil rights movement is still ongoing. And the Beatles are absolutely forthright about this. They will not play. And they managed to force an old stadium here or there to change the ticketing. Other ones, they just say, well, we're not going to play there. So what kind of impact do you think that has?
对，所以这是甲壳虫乐队带给美国的一种东西，但显然对甲壳虫乐队来说，去美国也是一次朝圣之旅，因为这里孕育了他们最喜爱、最受其启发音乐。我们说过，他们特别受美国黑人音乐的影响。因此，在1964年他们在美国巡演期间出现的一个问题是：他们会在实行种族隔离的体育场演出吗？因为那在当时依然非常普遍。民权运动仍在进行中。而甲壳虫乐队对此态度绝对坚决。他们绝不演出。他们设法迫使某个地方的老体育场更改了售票规定。至于其他的，他们直接说：“好吧，那我们就不去那里演出了。”所以你认为这会产生什么样的影响？
I think it's massive. I mean, first of all, it shows that they are not going to bend the knee. They are principled. There are things that they think are important. They care about. There's the fact that they will not play in front of segregated audiences. And then almost maybe more important in their press conferences where people hang on every word when asked what groups do they like. they list all these black groups and they talk about Smokey Robinson and the Miracles and they talk
我认为影响极其巨大。首先，这表明他们绝不屈服。他们是有原则的。有些事情他们认为很重要，他们会在乎。事实就是他们绝不在实行种族隔离的观众面前演出。接着，或许更重要的是，在他们的记者招待会上，人们对他们的每一句话都洗耳恭听，当被问及他们喜欢哪些乐队时，他们列举了所有这些黑人组合，他们谈到了斯莫ok·鲁宾逊（Smokey Robinson）和奇迹乐队（The Miracles），他们谈到了……
about the Supremes and they mention so many black musicians and acts and it's not calculated that's just what they love that's what they love but they're it certainly I think is a beautiful moment when they when they're in New York and the you know the first days of their arrival they get given the chance to kind of DJ on various radio stations, don't they? And they're just endlessly playing black female groups. Yeah. Because that's what they love. That's that kind of great influence.
至高无上乐队（The Supremes），他们提到了如此多的黑人音乐人和表演者，这并不是刻意算计出来的，这就是他们所热爱的，这就是他们所爱的东西。但当他们在纽约以及抵达的那前几天，有机会在各大广播电台客串当DJ时，这无疑是一个美妙的时刻，不是吗？他们只是在没完没了地播放黑人女子组合的歌。对。因为那是他们所爱之物，那是那种伟大的影响。
And so that sense of the fact that they're not just musicians, but that what they say might matter. I mean, that lasts through 1964 and it lasts through 1965. And there is an assumption that the Beatles will always give interesting copy, but that may be the potential for them to say something that might ultimately turn out to be inflammatory. Yes. There's a constant expectation from the minute the Beatles arrive on the scene, and it's going so well, and it keeps getting bigger and bigger and bigger success, success, success, smash hit, smash
所以那种感觉——他们不仅仅是音乐人，他们所说的话可能也很重要——这种影响力一直持续到1964年和1965年。人们普遍认为甲壳虫乐队总能提供有趣的话题，但这其中也蕴含着他们说出最终可能具有煽动性言论的潜在风险。是的。从甲壳虫乐队登上舞台的那一刻起，人们就有一种源源不断的期待：既然一切都进展得如此顺利，并且成功、成功、更大成功、大获成功、大获……
smash hit, smash hit, when is the bubble going to burst? And so the pump is primed for something to go wrong. So in March 1966, there's a journalist called Boring Cleave, who has known the Beatles very well, known them for about three years, has kind of friends with them. She does, she interviews each one of the Beatles, and it runs in the press as in what it's like to, you know, to be a beetle. Yeah. And one of the interviews is with John, and he has been reading quite a lot about religion, and he gives Maureen some good copy.
大获成功、大获成功，泡沫什么时候才会破裂？所以社会各界已经做好了准备，随时准备看事情出错。因此，在1966年3月，有一位名叫莫琳·克利夫（Maureen Cleave）的记者，她对甲壳虫乐队非常了解，认识他们大约三年了，可以说是他们的朋友。她采访了甲壳虫乐队的每一位成员，采访内容作为“当甲壳虫是一种怎样的体验”在媒体上刊登。对。其中一篇采访对象是约翰，他当时一直在阅读大量关于宗教的书籍，他给莫琳提供了一些很有料的内容。
So he says, Christianity will go, it will vanish and shrink. I needn't argue about that. I'm right, and I'll be proved right. We're more popular than Jesus now. And so this runs in the British press, and nobody in Britain could care less about it. Yeah. And these articles then get, they get sold on to publication in America and they appear and still nobody really pays any attention to it. But then there are people in the Bible Belt in America who are not keen on the Beatles, sees the Beatles long hair as satanic.
于是他说：“基督教将会消亡，它会消失并萎缩。我无需为此争论。我是对的，而且事实会证明我是对的。我们现在比耶稣更受欢迎。”于是这段话刊登在了英国媒体上，而英国根本没有人对此感到哪怕一点点在意。对。随后这些文章被卖给美国的出版物并发表出来，结果依然没有人真正去关注它。但接着，美国圣经带（Bible Belt）的一些人对甲壳虫乐队并无好感，他们将甲壳虫乐队的长发视为撒旦的象征。
Some of them aren't keen on the whole anti-segregation stage. And when some of these people read what John has said, they're less than enthused, don't they? They're less than enthused. It's funny because we're in 1966, but it's kind of a, before the internet, it's an internet moment. Because today, John would have said that on Wednesday at 3 o'clock in the afternoon, and they'd be outrage. Yeah. On Thursday, this is an interview he does with Maureen Cleve. it takes a while.
他们当中有些人对整个反种族隔离的立场也没有好感。当其中一些人读到约翰说过的话时，他们的热情可想而知了——他们对此毫无热情。这挺搞笑的，因为我们正处于1966年，但这却是一种“互联网时代”的时刻。因为如果放在今天，约翰在周三下午3点说了这话，立刻就会引发轩然大波。对。而在周四——这是他和莫琳·克利夫的采访——这需要一段时间。
It actually takes quite a while for it to finally surface and find the right person to hate it. And then it becomes this explosion, this huge controversy. And the article comes out in England and then makes its way across to the states. It takes some time,
这其实需要相当长的一段时间，它最终才会浮出水面，并找到合适的人去对它恨之入骨。然后这就成了一场爆发，一场巨大的争议。这篇文章在英国发表，接着流传到了美国。这需要一些时间，
but then it starts to pick up traction. and the Beatles are coming back to America for a tour. And by the time they're ready to leave Britain to fly to New York, all hell is breaking loose. And the huge question for listeners is, will this finish the Beatles off? Is this the end of the Beatles? And there's literally only one way to find out. and that is to watch our second episode where we will kind of be moving
但随后它开始产生影响力。而甲壳虫乐队正准备回到美国进行巡演。当他们准备离开英国飞往纽约时，简直是一团糟。对于听众来说，最大的问题是：这会毁了甲壳虫乐队吗？这是甲壳虫乐队的末日吗？字面意义上只有一个方法能找到答案。
from the red album to the blue album. Okay, well, you just gave it away. Kind of I did, but I kind of think. People probably know that... This is a bit of a spoiler, but it did end the Beatles and their career ended in 66, and they all went into real estate. So find out how the Beatles got on
那就是观看我们的第二集，我们将从红专辑过渡到蓝专辑。好吧，你刚刚剧透了。某种程度上我是这么做了，但我觉得……人们大概都知道……这是一个小剧透，但它确实结束了甲壳虫乐队，他们的职业生涯在66年结束了，然后他们都去搞房地产了。所以去寻找甲壳虫乐队是如何……
as real estate developers in New York, or alternatively, we'll stick to the timeline of what actually happened. And Tom, I'm just curious. Is there any way that fervent listeners like myself can have access to this episode without waiting? Well, Conan, it will blow you away. But there is. What do you mean?
作为纽约的房地产开发商过得怎么样吧，或者换句话说，我们还是会坚持真实发生过的时间线。汤姆，我只是好奇。像我这样的狂热听众，有没有什么办法不用等待就能听到这一集？好吧，科南，这会让你大吃一惊的。还真有。你这话什么意思？
You can go to the rest is history.com and you can sign up there and you can get immediate access to it and a host, a host of other benefits. It is unbelievable value. This is incredible. It's so exciting. And I'm so glad to share it with you and to share it with you, the listener. We will be back. Thanks so much for watching us or listening, depending whether you're watching or listening to us. Bye-bye.
你可以前往therestishistory.com，在那里注册，你就可以立即收听这一集以及海量的其他福利。这绝对是难以置信的超值享受。这太不可思议了。太让人兴奋了。我很高兴能与你分享，也希望能与你——屏幕前的听众分享。我们还会回来的。非常感谢大家观看或收听我们的节目，取决于你是通过观看还是收听。再见。
Goodbye. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. Some of those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant
再见。纵观历史，庆祝一直意味着给予。所以在农神节（Saturnalia）上，罗马人会分发各种各样的礼物。三位东方博士送出了黄金、乳香和没药，而维多利亚时代的人则绝对喜欢用纸把东西包起来，再用缎带系上。其中有些是可爱的举动，但我不知道它们是否稍微有点过于奢侈了……
for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers, why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history? Club Membership. It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows and you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the cool
对于寻常的圣诞早晨来说。所以在今年，我向我们的听众和观众提出这样一个建议：为什么不送一份更有意义的礼物呢？为什么不把《历史其余部分》（The Rest is History）的俱乐部会员资格作为礼物送出去呢？对于任何比起礼篮更喜欢汉尼拔（Hannibal）的人来说，这是最有眼光的选择。你可以享受无广告收听，获得每周独家福利节目，提前观看现场演出，并拥有专属的深度剖析系列节目。此外，最棒的是，今年特别礼品版的《历史其余部分》俱乐部会员资格还附带一件轰动一时的独家T恤。这会让你成为所有邻居羡慕的对象，你社区里所有最酷的人（如果这样的人真的存在的话）都会对你投来羡慕的目光，并希望花更多的时间和你在一起。所以只需前往 therestishistory.com 并点击“礼物”（Gifts）。网址是 therestishistory 点 com，请点击“礼物”。
people in your neighbourhood, if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to therestishistory.com and click on gifts. That is the restishistory dot com and please click on gifts. Hello there, it's James Holland and Al Murray, hosts of WW2Pod, we have ways of making you talk. Yes, so Al and I have been on The Restis History a few times now, haven't we out? We've been talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic, and if you've been enjoying their recent series on the invasion of Norway, the fall of France, and the Battle of Britain, then we have good news for you. That's right, Jim. We have our own show all about the fascinating history of the Second World War. We've been going for longer than
大家好，我是詹姆斯·霍兰德（James Holland）和阿尔·默里（Al Murray），我是二战播客《我们有办法让你开口》（WW2Pod, We Have Ways of Making You Talk）的主持人。没错，所以阿尔和我已经上过好几次《历史其余部分》了，对吧，阿尔？我们和汤姆、多米尼克一起畅聊了二战的方方面面，如果你一直很喜欢他们最近关于入侵挪威、法国沦陷以及不列颠战役的系列节目，那么我们有个好消息要告诉你。没错，吉姆。我们有自己的节目，专门讲述第二次世界大战迷人的历史。我们制作的时间甚至比……
the Second World War itself, haven't we, James? And longer than the rest is history. Twice a week, WW2Pod, we have ways to make you talk, discusses the fascinating people, the incredible innovations and the terrible tragedies of this, I think, the most important people. period of history of all time. Absolutely. The Battle of Hastings. I've got nothing on this. It's 1940, where it's all at. This past year alone now, we've done series, haven't we, on Dunkirk, the Battle of Britain, Hitler's last days in Berlin, the dropping of the atomic bombs.
第二次世界大战本身还要长，对吧，詹姆斯？而且比《历史其余部分》还要长。每周两次，《我们有办法让你开口》探讨二战中迷人的人物、不可思议的创新以及可怕的悲剧——在我看来，这是人类历史上最重要的时期。绝对的。黑斯廷斯战役（The Battle of Hastings）跟这个完全没法比。1940年才是重头戏。仅在过去的一年里，我们就做过关于敦刻尔克、不列颠战役、希特勒在柏林的最后日子以及投放原子弹的系列节目。
And we've also explored the women of SOE, Auschwitz, and the nerve-wracking siege of Malta. And in a midst of all this, we take our listeners' family stories and give them an airing so that people can tell the story of what happened to their Uncle Albert, where maybe they were involved with the siege of Malta. and we're doing loads of naval chat at the moment on the main show, such as the fight against the U-boat Wolfpacks in the Atlantic War. So now is a really fantastic time to subscribe and get yourself a bit more nautical. So, search, We Have Ways, wherever you get your podcasts,
我们还探讨了特别行动处（SOE）的女特工、奥斯威辛集中营以及扣人心弦的马耳他围城战。不仅如此，我们在主节目中还会采纳听众的家族故事并将其公之于众，让人们能够讲述他们的阿尔伯特叔叔身上发生了什么故事，或许他们曾参与过马耳他围城战。而且我们最近在主节目中正在做大量的海军话题，例如大西洋海战中对抗德国U型潜艇狼群的战斗。所以现在绝对是订阅并感受更多航海历史的绝佳时机。因此，无论你在哪里收听播客，只需搜索“We Have Ways”，
and we look forward to you, joining us. Prepare to Board, we have Ways to Make You Talk with me, Al Murray, and James Holland. Thank you. Hello there, I'm William Drimple. I am one of the hosts. of Empire, the Global History Podcast from Gollhanger. You may remember my appearances on The Rest is History when we talked about Afghanistan and the East India Company. As the Ashes returned down under, Anita Anna and I have launched a brand new Empire series on the history, politics, and extraordinary
我们期待你的加入。准备登船吧，《我们有办法让你开口》由我阿尔·默里和詹姆斯·霍兰德为您呈现。谢谢。大家好，我是威廉·达林普尔（William Dalrymple）。我是哥汉姆公司（Goalhanger）全球历史播客《帝国》（Empire）的主持人之一。你可能还记得我曾做客《历史其余部分》谈论阿富汗和东印度公司的节目。随着“火炬”板球对抗赛（The Ashes）重返南半球，安妮塔·阿南德（Anita Anand）和我推出了一档全新的《帝国》系列节目，聚焦板球的历史、政治以及非凡的文化力量。
cultural power of cricket. In the first episode, we dig into the origin of the ashes, England versus Australia, a rivalry born in the age of empires, and still shaping identity on both sides of the world. Then we travelled to India where cricket began with an impromptu beach match and evolved into a sport that mirrored and sometimes magnified the country's communal divides. We also talk about the great Tiger Borti who revolutionised Indian cricket in the 1960s. And for members of the Empire Club, we go still further from the great West Indian players who stood up to racism to the South African cricketers who challenged apartheid at real personal risk.
在第一集中，我们深入探讨了“火炬”对抗赛的起源——英格兰对阵澳大利亚，这是一场诞生于帝国时代的宿敌之战，至今仍在塑造着世界东西两端的身份认同。然后我们前往板球发源地印度，它从一场即兴的海滩比赛演变成了一项能够反映并有时会放大该国社群分裂的运动。我们还谈到了在20世纪60年代革新了印度板球的伟大球星小蒂格尔·帕陶迪（Tiger Pataudi）。而对于《帝国》俱乐部的会员，我们探讨得更深：从站出来抗击种族主义的伟大西印度群岛球员，到冒着巨大个人风险挑战种族隔离制度的南非板球运动员。
If you want the full sweep of how cricket changed empires and how, Empires change cricket, just search for Empire wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想全面了解板球是如何改变帝国，以及帝国又是如何改变板球的，只需在你获取播客的任何地方搜索“Empire”。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。